let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
number one early voting is underway and
um record turnouts are
being reported here's a story from the
news times it says with less than three
weeks to go before the november third
election more than 14 million americans
have voted in the fall election
reflecting an extraordinary level of
participation
despite barriers being erected by the
coronavirus pandemic
in georgia this week voters waited as
long as 11 hours to cast their ballots
on the first day of early voting
in north carolina nearly one in five of
roughly 500 000
who have returned mail ballots did not
vote in the last presidential election
in michigan um more than a million
people
have already voted and then it goes on
to say much of the early voting seems to
be driven by
enthusiasm among democrats so you know
you could
believe that or not take it with a grain
of salt i know a lot of my listeners
maybe don't want to
don't want to hear this but there does
appear to be
a lot of enthusiasm among voters who
hate trump and want him gone
this this is what i expected i expected
a massive anti-trump turnout
that's gonna happen it didn't happen in
2016 there was not a massive anti-trump
turnout and i think
i think part of the reason for that is
that everyone thought he'd lose anyway
and um also because hillary clinton was
so
just unappealing as a human being
you might say biden is unappealing too
but it's it's not to the level of
hillary
nobody is at the level of hillary
clinton clinton when it comes to be
comes to being
viscerally unappealing right so um
that's the way things are trending the
good news is that the election isn't
over yet there are still three weeks to
go
but as i've been saying for a long time
now trump needs to do something make
some kind of
pitch have some kind of strategy
to mobilize other than just the mega
crowd
yeah you need the mega crowd you've
already got them
that's good you're going to need more
than that
there aren't enough people who wear maga
hats to win the election you cannot you
cannot that's your base that your core
supporters great
you need more than that he needs to
reach the sorts of people
who don't love him personally maybe
don't even like him personally
but also don't like the democrats and
right now are trying to decide
i could be wrong this is just my my
guess
my guess is that there are a lot of
people right now
who are undecided only because not
because they're trying to choose between
trump and biden
they're trying to choose between voting
for trump or not voting at all
and so trump needs to have some sort of
a strategy for mobilizing and reaching
out to those voters
who are on the fence right now between
not voting at all at all or voting for
him he has to give them a reason to vote
for him
he needs to make those voters feel
better about voting for him
he used to do something in his norm his
normal routine with the rallies and the
tweeting and everything
that's not going to be enough and so i
am worried about this
i'm worried that three weeks from the
election i have no idea what the trump
campaign strategy is other than
just do all the same stuff he always
does that's not a campaign strategy
that again that's a that's a campaign
strategy for the people who are already
excited about you
i don't know what his strategy is for
the for the other mill
that that whole pool of millions of
people who are who are gettable you can
get them
but they're not going to come to a rally
because they're not that excited
what is this strategy for those do you
know does anyone know
it doesn't seem like there is one and
that that worries me
um i know trump kind of ad-libbed
ad-libbed his way to to to the win in
2016 very impressive
i i don't think we should assume it's
going to happen at second time
conditions are very different so i'm
concerned about that
number two during day three of the
hearing yesterday uh wednesday there was
a moment
from amy coney barrett that if she were
a liberal it's only one i'll play this
for you because if she were a liberal
this moment would already be turned into
merchandise and and t-shirts and bumper
stickers and everything else
uh here it is listen to this to be clear
as
i said i think in response to this
question yesterday
i do share justice claire's approach to
text
originalism and textualism but in the
litany of cases that you've just
identified
the particular votes that he's he cast
are a different question
of whether i would agree with the way
that he applied those principles
in particular cases and i've already
said
you know and i hope that you aren't
suggesting that i don't have my own mind
or that i couldn't think
independently or that i would just
decide like let me see what justice
scalia has said about this in the past
because i assure you i have my own mind
um but everything that he said
um is not necessarily what i would agree
with or what i would do if i were
justice barrett that was justice scalia
so i share his philosophy but i've never
said that i
would always reach the same outcome as
he did i assure you i have my own mind
she says that
that was a good moment from barrett i'm
not saying that i think it was some kind
of epic
smackdown of some sort but uh or or any
kind of uh
empowering feminist anthem i'm saying
that in our vapid culture if barrett was
liberal
that's how it would be seen i mean
during the the vice presidential debate
camilla harris said um i'm speaking and
feminists turn that into you know the
most brilliant comeback in the history
of debates
they turn it into a shirt like right
away you see the shirt here
um so that's the way that goes meanwhile
another moment from the hearings uh this
one was
also seized upon by the left um
in an incredibly dishonest way i know
that won't surprise you but
first watch watch this do you think
brown versus board of education super
president is that
you're not aware of any effort to go
back to the good old days of segregation
by a legislative body is that correct
that is correct okay so what's the news
there
not immediately obvious to a normal
person you see that you think okay
what's what's the problem
well they're making a big deal out of
the fact that lindsey graham said
good old days of segregation obviously
sarcastically in the same vein that
somebody might say
uh when they're told they need a root
canal by the dentist they might say oh
great
does anyone you hear that do you think
oh that person must love root canals
um or you know if someone says oh just
what i they you run into traffic and you
say
just what i need the way the left is
responding to what lindsey graham
i guess if they were in the car with you
they would think why do you need traffic
what are you
what are you talking about doesn't
compute um
so here's jamie harrison graham's
opponent in south carolina
he said lindsey graham just called
segregation the good old days
the good old days for who senator it's
2020 not
1920 act like it then there are articles
like this in mediaites um
it says senator lindsey graham raised
eyebrows during his questioning of judge
amy coney barrett
when he asked the supreme court nominee
how much confidence she has in the
landmark
brown versus board of education um
uh how much country she has in
i don't know this is phrase anyway
if she was asked if this was a super
president brown versus board of
education
uh anyway it says curiously however
senator graham who finds himself in a
hotly contested re-election
also asked um if it's it also referred
to the good old days of segregation
the article says wait what good old days
of segregation i mean
he could have been joking despite the
lack of any facial cue or body language
suggesting sarcastic hyperbole
however senator graham got a lot of
attention during a recent debate with
his political photo jamie harrison
when he said that young black people and
immigrants could go anywhere in south
carolina but added you just need to be
conservative
um and it goes on from there just
to call this to call this merely bad
faith would be a massive understatement
yeah i'm sure you're really confused
about this aren't you i don't know was
he serious or not i have no idea
maybe he was really openly and publicly
reminiscing in a favorable way about
segregation
while on tv in a supreme court hearing
during an election
he could have been who knows
um okay let's see here there was one
other thing
one other thing i wanted to mention from
the hearings that i didn't get a chance
to yet this article from cnn
uh headline is amy coney barrett says
she owns a gun
but could fairly judge a case on gun
rights obvious implication is
she can't if she if you own a gun how
can you be fair in judging a case on gun
rights
all i'm going to say in response to this
is imagine during the sonia sotomayor
confirmation in 2009
imagine the following headline sonia
sotomayor says she's a woman
but could fairly judge a case on women's
rights
something something tells me i i sort of
doubt that you we would have ever seen
that headline i don't think we did
i could go back and check uh number
three scary stuff here tommy lee
former rock star speaking with the big
issue uh
has said that he might leave the country
if trump is reelected
here he is he says dude i swear to god
if that happens that i'm coming over to
visit the uk
i'm out of here i'll go back to my
motherland go back to greece
and get a house on one of the islands
and then he goes on from there talking
about how bad
trump is to me the big headline here is
that tommy lee is still alive
i i honestly thought that he died years
ago i'm not i'm not trying to be funny i
really thought that
so congratulations to tommy lee first of
all on not being dead
as far as him leaving the country well
now that i know he's still alive
you know i couldn't bear to lose him
again i can't lose him twice
in fact i'll probably vote for biden
just to keep tommy lee here i am now a
single
issue voter and my issue is
making sure tommy lee does not leave us
because i
i don't want to live in a country like
that i don't know about you number four
um here is uh
it's always it's always tough when you
take a politician like camila harris and
you try
to make her seem human and but rachel
maddow msnbc they did what they could to
get a human moment out of camila harris
and here's how that went
i just realized that i would kick myself
if i didn't just
ask you uh before i let you go if
you noticed the fly on vice president
pence's head
at the time during the vlog all right or
if that was something that only
we could see it at home could you see it
sitting next to him
did you have feelings about like did you
have the
instinct to
you know
i just you know i think that it's
important that we kind of
um find a way all of us
to move on and you know kind of
fly away from this subject onto
something else
yeah summer harris you are very kind and
let's just spare a thought right now for
the people who have to write closed
captions
for this portion of the interview uh and
for those who have to transcribe it
because they're going to have no idea
how to convey what we just communicated
that just it makes my skin crawl doesn't
it it
it's it's almost as bad as hillary
clinton
trying to pretend to be to be you know
not a robot um that's that's tough to
watch tough to get through
okay number five my producer sent me
this story i haven't read it ahead of
time
i never read this stuff ahead of time if
you can't tell um
but here's the story from the bristol
post it seems promising
headline is man who farted in uber ends
up in court
and then says let's see breaking
breaking wind in the back of an uber
taxi cost a man a suspended jail term
but the repercussion for the taxi driver
was that he has to return to his native
bulgaria
drunken james mallett let rip as
alexander bonchev was driving him to
chaser's nightclub in kingswood
bristol crown court heard it was the
final straw for the cabbie
who after suffering abuse abuse from
other fairs told malt to get out of the
vehicle because you know you farted so
get out of the vehicle
um and at that point mallet began
hitting the driver
and uh so then there was a fight okay so
he's
so he's not going to jail for farting in
the uber he's going to jail for
first he farts on the uber it sounds
like and then he beats up
starts beating up the uber driver um
insult to injury there and he's in and
so that's that's what
what gets him prosecuted so i was hoping
listen
i would i would be fully in favor of a
law that
penalizes people for flatulence in
certain scenarios
i think in an uber you know is is one
big one on a plane i've i have in the
past shared my own experience we've all
had experiences like this
sitting next to someone who with chronic
flatulence um
it is it is it's it's biological warfare
you shouldn't allow biological terrorism
especially on a plane and so i'd be in
favor of prosecution
in in circumstances like that sounds
like that's not what happened here
but it gives us something to aspire to
in any way well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt walsh show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content